there's a there's a contradiction here
just on the question of covet is coveted
really dangerous
or is it just not that big a deal right
now the left is is
implicitly telling us both at the same
time because they're changing their
argument depending on their political
point of view but fauci he's sticking to
his story
dr fauci is saying that the the pandemic
is so
bad right now that that your kid
very likely maybe he'll be able to go to
summer camp maybe he won't
you're gonna have to monitor this
situation very carefully and probably he
shouldn't play outside
can they send their kids to summer camp
can they
allow them to play again on playgrounds
you know it is conceivable that that
will be possible margaret because what
we're seeing
is you know as you just mentioned on the
piece we now have
3 to 3.5 million vaccinations each day
if we keep up at that pace invariably
that's going to drive the rate and the
level of infections per day
to a much much lower level if we get
into the summer
and you have a considerable percentage
of the of the population
vaccinated and the level in the
community
gets below that plateau that's worrying
me and my colleagues in public health
it is conceivable that you'll have a
good degree of flexibility
during the summer even with the children
with things like
camps we don't know that for sure but i
think that's an
aspirational goal that we should go for
it is conceivable that if you do every
single
thing i tell you to do in perpetuity
maybe i'll let a little johnny go
outside for half an hour
in the sun it's an aspirational goal
it's an aspirational goal how about we
just do it
how about i'm no expert i don't have
very fancy medical degrees
i think that the kids can play outside
actually i've got some
empirical data here which is since the
beginning
of of the reign of fouchy beginning
last march i've 99.9
of the time ignored everything he said
i've occasionally i've had to acquiesce
because
i need to say travel somewhere on an
airplane and i've made a prudential
calculation and said okay it's better
that i
put the stupid mask on for a second and
fly to this place and give a speech
about how terrible fauci is
then not do that right but that's not
i'm not acquiescing in the sense that i
think he's he's right i've never really
thought the guy was right uh
i've just been living my life normally
and ignoring all of his dumb guidelines
and uh i'm fine not saying i'm
i couldn't come down with the the
woofloo or something and that would be
that unfortunate and i'm just i'm just
looking at the science here
and the risk is pretty low and the risk
to children
is infinitesimally low so
following the science here it would seem
that the kids can go out and play and
they should have been able to do that
from the very beginning but what
fouchy's
making here is not a scientific argument
he's making a political argument
right she's asking is is it okay for
kids to go play
and he goes look it's conceivable if you
do all this other stuff i want
if we get the numbers what the num what
do we mean if we get the public numbers
down what is the public numbers in
california matter to a kid in new york
if the kid is vaccinated or if he's even
not vaccinated but his parents are
vaccinated
those are specific cases but what fauci
is doing is he's holding
the individual cases as
as an incentive and saying you need to
get the
public matter you all need to obey what
i'm telling you to do
and then maybe in your individual cases
which are disconnected from the public
matter broadly
then maybe i'll let you and your kids go
out and play
and when i say he's not just talking
about summer camp he's actually talking
about letting your kids go out and play
he says that if you let your kids go out
and play they should wear a mask
yeah the children can clearly wind up
getting infected when we talk about what
you can do when you're vaccinated
you can certainly have members of a
family if the adults are vaccinated
and you're in the home with your child
you don't need to wear a mask and you
can have physical contact
when the children go out into the
community you want them to continue to
wear masks
when they're interacting with groups
from multiple households
now i don't want them to do that
actually so i mean sweet little june
is like two months old now so he's not
going to go out and see a lot of people
but if i had
older children right now i certainly
would not have them wear a mask
i would not listen to anything that this
this power mad sociopath has to say i
just
i just uh don't care the guy has
admitted to misleading people
on on this issue the idea that anyone uh
uh feels that he still has credibility
is just patently absurd
to me i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]